how long an established guy remember it
so you don't have to well people seem to
have very strong feelings about Man of
Steel audiences enjoy defending it
critics enjoy obliterating it trust me
I'll have my own words to say when it
finally comes to DVD but there is one
criticism that seems to carry over for
many people and that is that Superman
does too much moping the fun thing is
out of all the problems with this film I
find this one didn't really bother me so
much
I mean I don't think it was done well
but people argue that Superman should
not be a character who questions his
purpose or his identity he should be
simple and fun it then started to hit me
that this wasn't the first time I heard
this argument
I remember when Spiderman came out it
had very similar criticisms too much
Ang's too much drama too much oh and as
I started to go through the reviews and
critiques of a lot of comic book movies
I found that even the ones that got good
reviews still listed the emotional
scenes as - wynee which begs the
question are superheroes just whiny
bitches I think about how many of them
stand alone with their head down and
brooding in frustration a single tear or
a fuckload of tears always seems to
follow so is this the way superheroes
should be or are we transforming them
into something they're not again it
might make sense to connect these
incredibly famous comic book characters
to the great Greek myths when their
stories were told their powers and
abilities are what ultimately drew
people to them but as these gods and
heroes stayed longer and longer people
want to know more and more about who
they really are about their stories and
their turmoil all in the hopes of maybe
learning more about themselves thus many
of the Greek myths turned into
cautionary tales lying too close to the
Sun pushing the boulder up the hill
teaching life lessons and tough morals
without many people even realizing it
now at least probably at the time thus
their stories are still told even today
in many respects the evolution of the
superhero is much the same kids didn't
pick up a Superman comic because they
want to know about his psychological
journey
they picked it up because they want to
see him fly and hitch it they wanted to
see him do all the things we couldn't do
but wish we could do the movies and
serials that followed soon after
reflected this to people who tuned in to
watch Superman on TV or a Batman on the
big screen to see them fight crime and
look cool doing it there wasn't really
much analysis of what was going on
inside their heads
well these serials do have a charm all
their own I think many can admit that
they don't hold up the nomally well the
formula was often the same villain
causes trouble hero saves the day here
it looks cool while doing it it built
the serials and the comic stuck to this
formula chances are neither would last
very long but both of them made the
connection that superheroes represent
everything we want to be so it makes
sense to show how we could be like them
the goal was no longer to make them look
strong and invulnerable but instead
relatable and even fragile I mean hey
it's much easier to pretend where these
characters if they're made more human
and whether by accident or not they've
reflected the responsibilities of what
it means to do the right thing but if
the superhero is going to be more
relatable the enemies have to be more
realistic and even something that seems
as simple as the right thing can be a
very complicated issue in the real world
a super villain or a robber and a mask
is very easy to figure out but Wars
politics prejudice and so forth these
are a bit more complex so for a
superhero to always know or do the right
thing
is not always easy and the stories
logically have to reflect that so just
like the Greek myths the superhero knew
that if it wanted to last and be
timeless
it would have to reflect the most
important human needs at its core it
would need to adapt with time become
more personal make changes that would
create more interesting characters and
dilemmas this got me thinking about the
superhero film that did this right as
much as we'd like to make fun of the
camp enos of the original Superman it
does address several heavy elements
mortality responsibilities gaining great
power losing great power what you have
control over and what you don't have
control over it played with the morality
the ethics the choices of one who has so
much and the effect it has on the
world around it this wasn't written by
some Saturday morning cartoon writer
either this was written by Mario Puzo
the author of The Godfather and he
treated the mythos of this character
very seriously why because he saw the
human potential even the exact same
story can warn two very different
interpretations both Batman and Batman
Begins have the same setup child's
parents are shot grows up feeling guilty
dresses up like bad to avenge their
death
a classic logical conclusion but the
journey of our hero and Batman Begins is
dealt with in great detail seeing every
major development in his life and the
impact it has in creating who he is I'm
flesh and blood I can be ignored I can
be destroyed but as a symbol it's a
symbol I can be incorruptible I can be
everlasting something terrifying the
journey in the first Batman film is done
more in the shadows and off screen
leaving the development to a very simple
choice of select words look sometimes I
don't know what to think about this it's
just something I have to do
why because nobody else can both get
across exactly what they need to get
across it's just one is more shrouded in
detail and the other is more shrouded in
mystery but they both work then with
that said there's no doubt that the dark
harsh superhero has now become very
popular over the years maybe as a means
to fight against the kam penis of the
past or rebel against those who still
see them as mere kid stuff but the
question still remains is it warranted
are we going too far with the adult
stuff or are we evolving from the simple
action-packed basics this caused me to
look back at the often hated Superman
Returns and while I can't defend it as a
good film as many of the criticisms
against it I do agree with that being
that is often boring and very clumsy I
have to acknowledge that it was doing
some things very well like it did
address what it meant to have these
powers in today's world in a different
way that the past films didn't the
simple image of Superman floating in
space hearing all the problems of the
world
I still think sums up the weight and
pressure in one simple image no big
speeches are direct morals just one
simple shot what do you hear
hey I hear everything that's all you
need
I get all the anxiety and torment that
can beat down on a guy just from those
few lines but we're asking whether or
not this stuff can become too
heavy-handed and nowhere is that more
obvious in superhero films today than in
need Jesus symbolism yeah don't act like
you haven't seen this all over the place
why the hell do we need so much of it
yes there the martyr the saint the
everlasting guilt-trip that will make
you appreciate the sacrifice they make
what is the point the way I see it this
either shows how similar superheroes are
to Jesus I guess to show how incredible
they are in both power and humility or
how similar Jesus is to superheroes that
he had all this power and yet used it
for peace and kindness either way I
don't see why we constantly have to see
these similarities I think we have
enough variations on him already I don't
know why these guys can't just rely on
their own mythos I used to have long
hair too it doesn't mean you have to
make a comparison between me and him
those of you who are glasses he would be
a pretty awesome-looking hipster well
that's not the only thing that's going
too far
just like the exposing of nothing but
their superpowers in the past got old
maybe the exposing of all their
emotional baggage is starting to get a
little old to at least in the sense that
it's starting to become an overly
recognizable formula we're starting to
recognize certain scenes more and more
and people seem to think that just
making the scene without adding anything
else justifies a beam there oh this is
the flashback to childhood all of this
is the speech about what it means to be
here oh oh well this is the mistake that
causes injury to you and or your closest
friend oh this is when you realize you
need to be more responsible oh these are
the three or four overly dark scenes to
convince the doubters that superheroes
aren't just kids stuff yeah it's time to
become more and more noticeable and
maybe one or two of these films could
try a little harder and throw something
new with what we've seen formulas badly
repeated another film genres - and just
because the emotional weight in a
superhero film can be done bad doesn't
mean it shouldn't be done and too many
filmmakers credit die thing for the most
part they're still mixing it up enough
to create new problems and new solutions
in an effort
in world technology points of view
emotional understanding we're still
seeing these things evolve in our world
and our movie superheroes are doing well
to keep up with it
truth be told if they still want to be
relevant they need to keep up with it
if superheroes want to represent who we
want to be they must first understand
who we are and the more our heroes can
see that in themselves the more they can
understand who they're fighting for and
the more will cheer Ahmad because of it
and so the people who are seeing
superheroes as whiners nowadays I think
are more confusing whining for drama and
drama obviously is an essential part in
making something interesting like
anything we need investment in order to
care we need to relate to our heroes in
order to get behind them but yes they
need to actually do superhero east up to
throw a punch
show off their powers don't just fly
around the world questioning your
identity do things so in the end it all
comes down to balance you can't cheer
for a hero you know nothing about five
you also can't cheer for a hero who
doesn't do anything but mope both good
action and good character are needed to
keep the people cheering for more so
superheroes of the future continue
standing up for what you believe in but
never shy away from expressing why just
don't express too much I'm gonna stash
the critic and wait for another into
Garfield movie
yeah